va bene
molti di voi si staranno chiedendo come
fa un ragazzo così giovane ad essere
speaker altec cosa avrà fatto come avrà
fatto vedete per rispondere a tutte
queste domande
dobbiamo tornare indietro nel tempo di
circa 24 mesi
avevo 19 anni la mia era una
normalissima vita di un comune liceale
passata tra i banchi di un liceo
scientifico nella periferia di roma e
tra i piccoli grandi problemi che i
ragazzi di quell'età anno i primi amori
portare dei bei voti a casa e che fare
il sabato sera c'era anche quello di che
università scegliere una volta preso il
diploma
io mi ricordo che un giorno una mia
compagna di classe si presentò in aula
con un documento che lo stava qui che
erano le migliori università in italia
inserite in una classifica e ho notato
che tutti i compagni di classe me
compreso
l'avevamo accerchiata perché perché la
scelta dell'ateneo era influenzato dalla
posizione che questo aveva in quella
classifica
si può dire che la mia avventura alla
mia storia iniziata proprio in quel
momento perché in quel momento avevo
avuto un'idea
mi chiesi se i ragazzi hanno dei
benefici nel consultare una classifica
di università per scegliere l'ateneo
allo stesso modo un azienda potrebbe
avere dei benefici nel consultare una
classifica di studenti creare una
classifica di persone per trovare per
aiutare le aziende a trovare i migliori
talenti ma come si fa a creare una
classifica di persone mi rispose che
bisognava dargli un punteggio però come
fai a dare un punteggio
l'unica cosa che si può valutare il
curriculum quindi dovevo dare un
punteggio al curriculum però che cosa
fai realizzi un intelligenza artificiale
che ti legge tutti i curriculum degli
iscritti è impossibile
dovevo rivoluzionare quello che era il
mercato del reclutamento online quindi
decisi di insomma idea e questo portale
che non faceva inviare il curriculum ma
lo faceva compilare online utilizzando
le nuove tecnologie permesse dal web
in questo modo il sistema avrebbe
immagazzinato delle variabili e
attribuito con degli algoritmi un
punteggio
il risultato sarebbe stato un database
di persone con i cv graficamente uguali
tutti aggiornati e le aziende avrebbero
avuto i risultati della ricerca delle
risorse indicizzati wow
era sicuramente una bella idea e nessuno
ce l'aveva avuta quindi mi disse devo
essere il primo e in quel momento mi
sentivo un pochino cambiato
ero sempre il ragazzo del liceo il il
comune liceale però dentro di me si era
mosso qualcosa perché aveva un obiettivo
realizzare quel portale è come se per un
momento avesse alzato un po la testa per
vedere più lontano rispetto i miei
compagni
le mie esperienze nel nel mondo del
business erano inesistenti
sapevo programmare un pochino lo avevo
imparato da autodidatta alle scuole
medie
però non sapevo nulla di server di
database di management di grafica forse
le uniche due cose che avevo erano una
buona idea e la testa dura
decise quindi di contattare delle
società in internet delle web agency per
per avere dei preventivi e vedere quanto
costava a creare un sito del genere bene
i preventivi che riceveva erano di
centinaia di migliaia di euro
oltretutto io avevo iniziato a parlare
della mia idea alle persone a me vicine
che non capivano e mi dicevano matteo
monti concentrare su questo concentrati
sulle cose importanti
concentratevi sulla scuola
io non la volevo lasciare la scuola io
volevo solo di più però 100 mila euro
erano troppi soprattutto per una
famiglia normale quindi dovevo trovare
il modo di realizzare questo sito decisi
di trovare una via alternativa quella di
creare un team di giovanissimi che
credevano nel progetto e che quindi
realizzassero il sito insieme a me con
un pizzico di fortuna e un po di
passaparola sono riuscito a trovare quel
quei pochi ragazzi giusti e abbiamo dato
inizio allo sviluppo il budget che
avevamo a disposizione era veramente
limitato parliamo di poche migliaia di
euro
all'epoca non sapevo niente di business
angels venture capitalist investitori
sono andato dalla mia famiglia gli ho
detto voglio realizzare
questa cosa è fortunatamente hanno
creduto in me e con un po di sacrifici
mi hanno dato quei pochi soldi però
subito si presentano i primi problemi
perché il tempo di sviluppo del sito era
più lungo del previsto era un portale
veramente molto complesso e poi io avevo
un problema il problema era che al
momento del lancio per quanto l'idea
fosse una buona idea perché le società
si sarebbero dovuto iscrivere se non vi
erano candidati e viceversa perché una
risorsa una persona dove registrarsi al
sito se non c'erano le aziende quando la
finalità era metterli in contatto
a quel punto capii che prima del lancio
dovevo far registrare qualche azienda
per invogliare i ragazzi poi a
iscriversi battezza il sito e gonna è un
neologismo latino nato dalla fusione
delle parole
ecco io e omnia tutti tutte le cose e
iniziamo andare a decine di mail dalle
società che trovavo online dicendo sono
un ragazzo di 19 anni e ho questa idea
che sto realizzando potete ascoltarmi
il risultato fu sconcertante perché
nessuna società rispose alle mie email
oltretutto il tempo di sviluppo del sito
si era allungata un anno e il budget
stava per terminare ed ero consapevole
che nessuna azienda si sarebbe iscritta
prima del lancio in pratica stavo nella
merda è però nel frattempo io mi sono
trasferito a settembre di quell'anno a
milano a studiare economia anche io
scelsi la la prima università presente
in quella classifica alla bocconi e
decisi di cambiare strategia non potevo
andare dalle aziende perché i risultati
non li aveva ottenuti
dovevo partire dal basso cioè andare
dagli studenti
mi recai subito al media center quindi
il giornalino degli studenti
la radio dell'ateneo e il canale youtube
dei ragazzi e gli raccontare la mia
storia facendogli vedere anche il
portale che ancora non era terminato
devo dire che i ragazzi dell'università
mi hanno aiutato moltissimo sia nel
terminare il sito e in più mi avrebbero
garantito la promozione sui social
una volta lanciato e gonna
per la prima volta nel mio percorso
avevo intravisto uno spiraglio di luce e
quello che stavo facendo la mia storia
colpiva il cuore dei miei coetanei
a quel punto io mi resi conto che non
avevo soldi tanto più perché tra le
spese dei miei c'era una retta
importante universitaria non avevo un
business plan
non avevo un numeroso team non avevo
esperienza però quello che stavo facendo
piaceva quindi non potevo mollare
ebbene 24 mesi dopo quel periodo e
gommoni a punto com è una delle più
grandi realtà italiane nel mondo delle
risorse umane
abbiamo un portale che sta per
raggiungere le 300.000 persone e sono
700 le aziende che hanno aderito e
utilizzano la piattaforma tra cui
moltissime multinazionali il fatturato
ha raggiunto sin da subito i cinque zeri
abbiamo realizzato software per la
gestione del grazie
grazie abbiamo realizzato software per
la gestione del personale per la
gestione delle candidature e per il web
e per il wellness aziendale o aperto in
brasile e prima della fine di quest'anno
aprirò in asia con base a singapore la
mia faccia fortunatamente ha fatto il
giro del mondo ricevuto la medaglia
d'oro e il diploma d'onore dalla
provincia di milano ho avuto la
possibilità di parlare alte crunch ed
ecco oggi all ecologia ed che cosa è
cambiato dal matteo achilli liceale al
matera kg che vi sta parlando non è
cambiato nulla
io rimango lo stesso ragazzo che ero 24
mesi fa pieno di ambizioni e di paure
che però avuto una grande possibilità
quella di conoscere se stesso e di
scoprire quelle che sono le sue carte
ognuno di noi ha delle carte da giocare
e quindi non ho capito che non c'è
bisogno di conoscenze esperienze ho
soldi per raggiungere un obiettivo
i due requisiti sono avere appunto un
sogno un obiettivo e 2 conoscere se
stessi le mie carte una delle mie carte
era proprio la giovane età e io l'ho
capito lavorando perché soprattutto nel
mio settore il mondo del digitale non ci
sono
non ci sono esperti non c'è la storia si
sta si sta scrivendo adesso la storia
quindi non sono esperti coloro che hanno
i capelli brizzolati e questo
sicuramente ha giovato ha giocato a mio
favore i veri esperti del di internet
del digitale non hanno i capelli bianchi
e voglio raccontarvi un piccolo episodio
che che è successo che mi è successo e
che permette di capire quanto a volte ha
giovato a favore la mia alla mia età e
sono stato invitato poco dopo il lancio
di agonia da una grossa società di head
hunting in un bell'hotel al centro di
milano per questo evento a cui ha
partecipato una un'importante persona
forse uno degli uomini più potenti della
terra
parlo di un amministratore delegato
mondo di una delle più grandi aziende
del mondo americana con un fatturato di
150 miliardi di dollari e
c'erano moltissime persone io per ora la
ero più giovane e dopo averlo ascoltato
parlare tutta la sera di economia delle
sue esperienze di come funziona una
grossa società americana decisi che era
arrivato il momento di fare un
intervento per aver la sua attenzione
chiesi la parola mi alzai e gli dissi
premessa la cosa che mi aveva colpito
era che lui se non altro per via
anagrafiche ha spiegato che stava per
abbandonare il suo incarico all'interno
dell'azienda
io gli dissi quando la società per cui
lavori si riterrà troppo maturo per
lavorare come amministratore delegato
che assumo io questo provocò delle
risate sicuramente tra i partecipanti il
l'organizzatore dell'evento mi presentò
quasi scherzando dicendo lui e matteo
achilli il nostro zuckerberg è appunto
questo amministratore delegato viene da
me mi diede il suo biglietto da visita e
mi disse quando diventerai veramente lo
zac alberghi italiano verrò a lavorare
per te vedete l'italia è un paese
bellissimo fatto da gente eccezionale ha
però qualche problema dalla burocrazia a
ogni tanto qualche qualche mentalità
particolare questi problemi allontanano
i giovani dall'italia e
e questa è una cosa che che non deve
assolutamente accadere
questa è una cosa che non deve
assolutamente accadere tant'è che io ho
due sogni o due grandi sogni premessa
importante ricordare che mentre io sto
parlando il 50 per cento dei ragazzi
della mia età non lavora e a casa i miei
due sony sono uno professionale e uno
personale quello professionale è quello
di portare e donne a diventare una delle
società di riferimento nel mondo delle
risorse umane mondiali siamo forti in
italia nel design nella moda e nella
cucina ma siamo una periferia del mondo
digitale nel mondo di internet
l'altro sogno è forse ancora più
ambizioso è quello personale
io voglio rivolgermi direttamente a ai
miei coetanei alla mia generazione
raccontando di me parlando di me di
quella che è la di quella della mia
esperienza che dal niente sono riuscito
a trovare lavoro ad oggi a più di
centinaia di ragazzi eventi lavorano per
la nella mia azienda azienda che al
cento per cento mia e al mille per cento
italiana
parlare della mia storia affinché la
storia di materiali e di gomma non si sa
come forse adesso purtroppo in qualcosa
di atipico ma diventi la normalità
quella di avere successo in italia
vedete ad oggi quell'importante persona
quell'importante amministratore delegato
ancora non lavora ancora non lavora per
me nella mia azienda
però nel frattempo qualcosina ho fatto
grazie